en pleine crise mondiale sur le gaz la
ville de saint pétersbourg accueille à
partir d'aujourd'hui un forum gazier
plusieurs responsables internationaux
sont attendus les pdg de gazprom shell
ou encore ou élevés doivent s'entretenir
sur l'avenir du marché gazier
international elle les explications avec
notre correspondant sur place antoine
gayraud
se forme internationale du gaz de saint
pétersbourg rassemble tous les acteurs
clés tous les acteurs importants de ce
secteur le gaz qui se trouve au coeur de
l'actualité ces dernières semaines avec
la hausse des prix de l'énergie mais
aussi avec l'achèvement du chantier du
gazoduc nord stream 2 et sa mise en
service prochaine et entendre les
professionnels du secteur et bien la
transition écologique n'est pas encore
pour aujourd'hui gaz et pétrole reste à
l'heure actuelle incontournable
je suis sûr qu'une certaine
transformation aura lieu de cela prendra
probablement du temps
regardez combien de temps a duré la
discussion autour de la digitalisation
avant de devenir effectivement une
réalité et avant qu'on commence à
investir dans ce domaine
il en sera de même je pense pour
l'hydrogène dont une femme beaucoup
aujourd'hui
la première question est est produit cet
hydrogène donc à mon avis il y aura une
transition et pourtant nous ne pouvons
pas nier l'importance du pétrole et du
gaz pour le secteur énergétique
et donc cela requiert du temps il faudra
assez d'investissements et de
technologie prudence donc qu'on a
affaire à du moyen terme et non pas du
court terme
le secteur du pétrole et du gaz joue
toujours un rôle clé
[Musique]
avec le développement et la dynamique
actuelle du marché en termes des prix la
demande reste assez importante
rendez-vous maintenant à l'issue de la
session plénière point d'orgue de cette
10e édition du forum du gaz de saint
pétersbourg un événement l'aura compris
particulièrement suivie en raison de
l'actualité